[Music]
I'm sure you wouldn't be here if you
weren't aware that there is this primary
proto religion Paleolithic an age
worldwide and extent that seems to
involve the acquisition of extraordinary
power to heal or disrupt the community
the acquisition of this power obtained
through the intercession of intermediate
dis incarnate beings that are variously
called spirits demons Haruka's angels
powers principalities and that this
notion that somehow the mental universe
of human beings is an animated cosmos a
hierarchy of energies is there when the
dawn of self-reflection and reason comes
into being this seems to be almost the
proto condition of human thought and yet
it is very exotic to us as the
inheritors of a very 500 year long
tradition of positivism and rationalism
that has completely dehumanized the
universe completely taken away any
mystery or any hint of animate intent
that might have infused nature and
replaced it with instead instead with
the notion of nature as object nature as
property nature as something which is to
be cut apart and and dissected how many
of you happen to be at the John Ford
theater event
couple of weeks ago well I want to
recall something to you that happened
during that evening which was during the
question and answer period man got up
and said that he had thrown a hexagram
for the destiny of the planet and would
I discuss the hexagram and I did then
and I want to again because I've thought
about it I thought it was a profound
moment in the history of public policy
discussion that this hexagram of the
destiny of the planet which had been
spontaneously thrown by someone in the
audience should then serve as the spring
point for a discussion the hexagram that
had been thrown was work on what has
been spoiled changing into the caldron
the changing lines said work on what has
been spoiled by the father it seems to
me that we could take this throw and
it's change as an image around which to
build what we're trying to do this
weekend work on what has been spoiled
what has been spoiled in the exterior
world is the planet our stewardship has
run amok what has been spoiled on the
interior plain is the interior image of
the planet which is the feminine working
on what has been spoiled by the father
is an injunction to abandon the
patriarchal model the egocentric model
in favor of the kind of partnership
society that Rihanna Iser is arguing for
based on the scholarship of Maria gam
butis an archaic revival a return to
models in the past in the distant past
well then so what about the change the
changes to the cauldron the cauldron is
one of only two hexagrams in the eaching
that refer to an artificial object the
other one is the well which strictly
speaking is not an art of is you know in
this intermediate range because it's a
penetration of the earth but the
cauldron is clearly an image of the
synthetic not only is it a cast object
but it is the master implement of
cooking the primary transformation of
the natural into the synthetic that
informed the primitive world it is also
symbolic of the womb the alchemical
vessel also the pressure cooker the
dissolver the steamer so I think that
there was something as there always is
with the eaching something fairly
prophetic in this throw that shows us
the redemption of the planet as an
exterior task linked to the redemption
of the feminine within each of us as a
task of spiritual growth and redefine
'men
leading to this shamanic cauldron this
vessel in which an alchemical
transformation is to be wrought some of
you who are scholars of this stuff may
no mercy Leon's book the forge and the
crucible where he argues very forcibly
that the the phonic image of the shaman
is the Smith and that the Smith as the
worker of metal as the one who goes into
the bowels of the maternal matrix and
returns with rarefied metals that can
then be paradoxically fashioned into
objects of art
weaponry is exemplary of the movement of
the shaman figure into the more explicit
realm of Technos the creator shaman
recall Hephaestus in the Iliad he was
the armament to make for a dismantle to
beat armor of such wrought intensity
that when you looked into it you saw
villages and rivers and islands and
ships at sea and gods working the fates
of men in other words this summoning of
art and order out of the products of the
unconscious is a kind of open-ended task
the shaman is the archetype of the
artist the archetype of the Creator the
maker homo Faber the maker of tools and
I would argue that in the same way that
Iliad in the forge in the crucible
traces the evolution of proto
metallurgic shamanism into early
smithing and Hance into the more florid
expressions that you get in alchemical
literature in the same way that that was
done by Iliad it's possible to argue
that you can carry that process forward
and see in fact that the aspirations of
the 20th century in its most Faustian
expression the manipulation of matter
the taking control of the weather the
splitting and releasing of the energy in
the atom that these are all in fact
completions of explicitly defined
shamanic tasks it's just that somehow
the price of being able to work the
miracle was literally loss of soul by
virtue of having to opt in to the
metaphor that nature it herself had no
soul in other words it's like modern man
has made the journey into the realm of
the golem in order to be in the realm of
the golem you must shed your own soul
and leave it behind you well this is the
cultural situation that we inherit
jean-paul Sartre in his major opus I
think it was being a nothingness which
is sort of summed up 20th century for us
if he said nature is mute that is the
existential situation well to me this is
like an apotheosis of wrongheadedness
nature is not mute it must be that man
is deaf to hold that position you see
because nature reinforces the natural
set of conclusions which we tend to call
feminine that all things flow that
nothing is permanent that form comes
into being is sustained and
but there is a kind of round of eternal
return that worth is in the moment that
it is depth of felt experience that
empowers a life well-lived that these
are things which are all argued for by
this repressed point of view that has
survived them in modernism as only a
thin thread of tradition reaching back
beyond the collapse of the greco-roman
world to a time when these ideas
actually dominated and flourished
[Music]